[Music]
society is very it's very focused on
people's opinions and feelings when
actually science is it to be a scientist
to be trained to be the opposite of that
I think that I would deal I would take
great delight if someone turned up
tomorrow and said actually the universe
is not 13.8 billion years old it's six
thousand we actually made a mistake
there's this new evidence has come in
and it turns out that on London I would
actually genuinely be very excited but I
don't think it's gonna happen
but it would delight me it would not be
an assault on my very being indeed it
would it would be it would confirm that
my excitement would confirm to me what I
think of my being as being right who is
it it's as someone who delights in
intellectual challenge I and I think
that's that's trained to an extent in
its part of the scientific training but
it's also a wonderful way to be you know
imagine that every science book start
well of course we may be wrong but that
that's implicit in every science book it
should be probably explicitly stated of
course this might be wrong imagine if
every book of every philosophy if every
religious document began with that
imagining the Bible started of course we
might be wrong but in the beginning God
created through that form a void and
darkness was on the face of it that
would be rather refreshing I think it's
a refreshing position to take certain
see is the enemy of science you know
what's beautiful about that right off
the bat like he's basic we know that
science has gotten us farther than any
other tool we've ever had out or just
anything other than religion so to hear
him say that I think that that's
probably why science has triumphed
because of that wonderful humility that
willingness to change course that
willingness to find new evidence that
turns everything on its head and allows
us to update correct and upgrade what I
love about scientists is that they
they're never like that's definitely yes
like good scientists yeah unless it
actually is definitely there are some
things that are deaf like earth
definitely goes around the Sun
- this is definitely round but from the
frontier when we are in the act of
discovery stuff can go anyway yet so for
my next clip with Professor Brian Cox an
astrophysicist and a physicist walk into
an office what happens we have to talk
about wormholes yeah we love one who
doesn't love wormhole we loved you
somewhere moment let's just see how that
went down not to name drop but I talked
to Stephen Hawking about this actually
any point a bit of paper read written in
the 70s I think or eight is called the
chronology protection conjecture and the
problem with this paper problem with
wormholes is that you it looks like you
can build time machines because you can
you can get back into the past if you
can beat a light beam you can go back in
time and the wormhole would be the light
beam yes so he proposes that that's not
the way the laws of physics work is a
conjecture so it's an axiom armours so
what it's doing in technical language is
it's putting causality there's an axiom
the idea that cause and effect can't be
reversed so wormholes seem not to he's
right there they're impossible yes they
would say that if you tell a conjecture
seriously then when we have a quantum
theory of gravity so when we understand
gravity in more detail than Einstein's
general theory of relativity gives us
then there will be some physical process
that does not allow wormholes to exist
Jason you you have thoughts about cause
I well I'd be very interested in this
notion of once you start playing with
causality what does that say about
everything everywhere allows you to beat
a light beam you beat a light beam you
can disrupt your own path right so
normally we okay would think of things
beginning middle and cause-effect right
can an effect be a reason that a cause
happens I mean is that what he's
starting to play yes yes if in effect
yeah can cause a cause yeah can cause
its own cause can cause its own cause
snake eating its own tail if an effect
can cause its own cause Esther's hands
it's the hand drawing the hand that's
drawing it it's paradoxical if if it if
an effect can cause its own cause does
that require the absence of freewill it
has to have well it's a necessary
paradox so it tells us that freewill
doesn't exist but yet from the point of
view of subjectivity we feel free and
that's all that matters because
subjectivity is all we ever get to know
anyway
so it's one of those things where yeah
it's all predetermined if that's true
and freewill doesn't exist but it
doesn't really matter because I feel
free and I feel like I make decisions
every day and that's all that really
matters
[Music]